This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the 19th century short story, The Lady or the Tiger, a young man is caught having an affair with a princess. When the king finds out, the young man is subjected to a peculiar form of justice. He must choose between two identical doors. Behind one door is a beautiful lady. Behind the other, a ferocious tiger. If he picks the lady, he will marry her, according to the king's decree. If he picks the tiger,
这是《隐藏的头脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在19世纪的短篇小说《美女还是老虎》中，一个年轻人被发现与一位公主私通。当国王发现后，这位年轻人面临一种奇特的审判。他必须在两扇完全相同的门中做出选择。一扇门后面是一位美丽的美女。另一扇门后面是一只凶猛的老虎。如果他选了美女，根据国王的法令，他将娶她为妻。如果他选了老虎，
the beast will kill him. The princess uses her influence to find out which door hides the tiger and which one conceals the lady. But in so doing she also realizes that the lady is her rival. She doesn't want her lover to marry the lady. She also doesn't want him to be eaten by the tiger. As the young man confronts the two doors he beseeches the princess for help. She discreetly signals to him to pick the door on his right. Has the princess surrendered her lover to her rival? Or his jealousy won?
这头野兽会杀死他。公主利用她的影响力查明了哪扇门后藏着老虎，哪扇门后藏着美女。但这样做的时候，她也意识到美女是她的情敌。她不想让她的爱人娶那个美女。她也不想让他被老虎吃掉。当年轻人在两扇门前面对抉择时，他恳求公主的帮助。她低调地示意他选择右边的门。公主是把她的爱人拱手让给了情敌？还是嫉妒战胜了一切？
Has she marked the youth for death by tiger? The young man opens the door that the princess has indicated. And then... the story ends. It's left up to the reader to imagine what might have happened. Some might see this as a brilliant ending to a brilliant story. Others might find it deeply unsatisfying, even frustrating. Others might find it deeply unsatisfying, even frustrating. Today on the show, we examine a psychological trait that plays a surprisingly large role in shaping our behavior, perspectives, even our political beliefs.
她是在给这个年轻人判处虎口死刑吗？年轻人打开了公主暗示的那扇门。然后……故事就结束了。这一切留给读者去想象可能发生了什么。有些人可能会认为这是一个绝妙故事的精妙结尾。其他人可能会觉得这极不圆满，甚至令人沮丧。其他人可能会觉得这极不圆满，甚至令人沮丧。今天在节目中，我们来探讨一种心理特征，它在塑造我们的行为、视角甚至政治信仰方面发挥着出人意料的巨大作用。
The science of how we respond to uncertainty and the important lessons it has for how we organize our lives. This week on Hidden Brain. Are you the type of person who flies by the seat of your pants, who prefers to live life whimsically and spontaneously? Or do you prefer order and structure, meticulously planning out every detail in advance? At the University of Delaware, Danegal Goldthwaite Young studies how our capacity to deal with uncertainty has pervasive effects on our lives, our relationships, even our political affiliations. Dana Young, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me.
关于我们如何应对不确定性的科学，以及它对我们如何组织生活的重要启示。本周《隐藏的头脑》。你是那种随性而为、喜欢异想天开和顺其自然过生活的人吗？还是你更喜欢秩序和结构，提前一丝不苟地规划好每一个细节？在特拉华大学，达娜尔·戈尔德韦特·杨（Danegal Goldthwaite Young）研究了我们处理不确定性的能力如何对我们的生活、人际关系甚至政治归属产生深远的影响。达娜·杨，欢迎来到《隐藏的头脑》。非常感谢邀请我来。
Dana, I want to take you back to the year 1999. You had just moved to Philadelphia for grad school. The first week you were there, you were at a bar with some new friends and one of them started talking about improv comedy. I understand that you had some experience with this world? I did. So as an undergraduate at the University of New Hampshire, I had done improv comedy for four years in a company called Theater Sports and I had directed a long-form group. And so when these two young men talked about how they were in a professional improvisational comedy company
达娜，我想带你回到1999年。你刚搬到费城读研究生。你在那里的第一周，和一些新朋友在一家酒吧里，其中一个人开始谈论即兴喜剧。据我了解，你对这个领域有一些经验？是的。作为新罕布什尔大学的本科生，我在一个叫“剧场运动”（Theater Sports）的公司做了四年即兴喜剧，我还导演过一个长剧团。所以当这两个年轻人在谈论他们是一家专业的即兴喜剧公司时
called Comedy Sports, I couldn't believe it. We spoke the same language, and they said that their annual auditions were happening two days later. Danai agreed to go to the audition. I actually got cast. I was one of the six people of the 80 who made it into the company. And I got a wonderful call in my graduate dorm room from a man named Mike Young, who was the company's director, who congratulated me and told me that they were super excited
名叫“喜剧运动”（Comedy Sports），我简直不敢相信。我们说着同样的语言，他们说他们的年度试镜两天后就要举行。达娜同意去参加试镜。我居然真的入选了。我是80人中成功进入公司的6个人之一。我在研究生的宿舍里接到了一个美妙的电话，对方是一个叫迈克·杨（Mike Young）的男人，他是公司的导演，他向我道贺，并告诉我他们非常兴奋
to have me as a member of the company. And he said our new player training would be starting on Sunday at 5 p.m. and that new player training would go for 10 weeks. And I said, I'm so sorry. I don't think that I can actually be in this improv group. Wait, you're saying you declined? I literally declined and he was as shocked as you are right now.
能让我成为公司的一员。他说我们的新演员培训将于周日下午5点开始，新演员培训将持续10周。我说，非常抱歉。我想我实际上不能参加这个即兴喜剧团。等等，你是说你拒绝了？我真的拒绝了，他当时和你现在一样震惊。
He said, I don't understand. And I said, well, you told me the location of these trainings and it's on the other side of Philadelphia and I don't know how to get there and I haven't started my graduate school classes yet and I think I have to say no. And he said take the subway like everyone else and it's a wonderful part of town. You just walk down through Old City and it's fine. And I said, I'm nervous. I've never done it before. I'm afraid I might get, I don't know, mugged. It's dark. He said it's August. 5, mugged. It's dark."
他说，我不明白。我说，嗯，你告诉我这些培训的地点在费城的另一头，我不知道怎么去，而且我还没开始读研究生课程，我想我只能拒绝。他说坐地铁就像其他人一样，那是城里一个很棒的地方。你只要穿过老城（Old City）走过去就行了，没问题的。我说，我很紧张。我以前从来没去过。我害怕我可能会，我不知道，被抢劫。天黑了。他说现在是八月。5点，被抢劫。天黑了。"
He said, it's August. 5 p.m. is not dark in August. And he said, listen, Dana, do me a favor. Just come to the first rehearsal, just the first one, and then just see what happens. And so I did. And how did it go, Dana? It was, first of all, the walk from the subway stop to the location of the rehearsal was beautiful. It was through Society Hill and Queen Village. It was cobblestone streets and cute little coffee shops. So, yeah, he was right. And no, I didn't get mugged. And it was life-changing. mugged and it was it was life-changing. So what I loved about the early trainings was learning about some of the guidelines of improv comedy which had to do with yes and which is accepting the
他说，现在是八月。八月份下午5点天还没黑呢。他说，听着，达娜，帮我个忙。就来参加第一次排练，就第一次，然后看看会发生什么。于是我照做了。结果怎么样，达娜？首先，从地铁站到排练地点的步行过程非常美妙。那是穿过社会山（Society Hill）和皇后村（Queen Village）。那是鹅卵石街道和可爱的小咖啡馆。所以，是的，他是对的。不，我没有被抢劫。这改变了人生。被抢劫，而且它改变了人生。所以早期培训中我最喜欢的是了解一些即兴喜剧的准则，这与“是的，而且”（yes and）有关，也就是接受
offer that your scene mate gives and then just building upon the last offer given. Early in those trainings I realized that while I was very funny and I made people laugh and I was very goofy and physically funny, I actually don't think that I had ever learned how to be a very good improviser when I was an undergraduate. I realized that when I started scenes with a partner, I would tend to script the scene, which means instead of just giving an offer and then letting my seamate build upon it,
你的搭档在场景中给出的提议，然后在此基础上顺着上一个提议继续发挥。在那些培训的早期，我意识到虽然我很搞笑，能逗大家笑，而且我很滑稽、身体语言也很搞笑，但作为一个本科生，我其实觉得自己从来没有真正学会如何成为一个非常好的即兴表演者。我意识到，当我与搭档开始一个场景时，我往往会把场景剧本化，这意味着与其仅仅给出一个提议然后让我的搭档在此基础上发挥，
to exaggerate a bit, I would get on stage and say, hey, Betty, my sister, how are you? It's great to see you here in this candy store, which doesn't allow for your scene partner to add. Yeah, you've locked her into being your sister and locked yourselves into being in a candy store. Correct. But what it offered me was a sense that like,
夸张一点说，我会走上台说，嘿，贝蒂，我妹妹，你好吗？很高兴在这里的糖果店见到你，这并不允许你的场景搭档加入。是的，你把她锁定为你的妹妹，把自己锁定在糖果店里。没错。但它给我的感觉是，
I knew exactly what was going on, I didn't have to stress out so Mike would say let's try that again and this time just give one offer and then just listen and I think that I I think that it made me a much better improviser. Not long after they began doing improv comedy together Dana developed a crush a much better improviser. Not long after they began doing improv comedy together, Dana developed a crush on Mike. When she confessed this to him, Dana learned that Mike felt the same way.
我确切地知道发生了什么，我不用感到压力，所以迈克会说我们再试一次，这一次只给出一个提议，然后去倾听，我想这让我成为了一个好得多的即兴表演者。在他们开始一起表演即兴喜剧不久后，达娜对迈克产生了好感。当她向他表白时，达娜得知迈克也有同感。
The two began dating. A few months into the relationship, Mike asked Dana to go on a backpacking trip with him. The destination? Kauai. So we met in Honolulu, but we had to take a puddle jumper plane to get to Kauai. Well, when we landed in Honolulu,
两人开始交往。交往几个月后，迈克邀请达娜和他一起去背包旅行。目的地？考艾岛（Kauai）。我们在檀香山碰头，但我们必须乘坐一架小型支线飞机才能到达考艾岛。嗯，当我们降落在檀香山时，
I realized that my luggage with my clothing had never made it onto the plane from Newark, New Jersey. And I was so stressed out. I mean, I had my carry-on, which had, of course, my necessities and underwear and toiletries, but I didn't have any clothing. And Mike didn't see this as a huge deal, really. He said, well, turns out there's a Walmart right near
我发现装着我衣服的行李根本没有被搬上从新泽西州纽瓦克出发的飞机。我压力太大了。我的随身行李里当然有我的必需品、内衣和洗漱用品，但我没有任何衣服。迈克觉得这其实没什么大不了的。他说，嗯，原来考艾岛机场附近就有一家沃尔玛。
the airport in Kauai. Why don't we just get you a bathing suit, tank tops, and shorts, and flip-flops, and you have your sneakers on so we can still hike? And I think we're fine. But for a good 24 hours, I was stuck. I was stressed. I was angry. I felt really kind of out of control without my belongings. And I probably wasn't too pleasant to be around, even though we did go to Walmart. I got everything I needed. I learned later, actually, that Mike was pretty stressed about my reaction in that moment? Because he worried about, well, one, our kind of compatibility, because I was so stuck, but also about what would that say about how I might be able to deal with, you know, bigger crises in life, you know? And so I think that that concerned him.
我们为什么不去给你买件泳衣、背心、短裤和人字拖呢？你脚上穿着运动鞋，所以我们仍然可以去远足？我觉得我们没问题。但在整整24个小时里，我卡住了。我很焦虑。我很生气。没有了我的行李，我感到非常失控。尽管我们确实去了沃尔玛，我买齐了所需的一切，但我大概并不是一个很好相处的人。后来我其实了解到，迈克当时对我的反应相当焦虑？因为他担心，一方面是我们的契合度，因为我卡在那里出不来，但同时也担心这说明我以后该如何应对生活中更大的危机呢？所以我觉得这让他担忧。
In some ways, I'm hearing an echo of what you told me a second ago about improv because of course when the luggage didn't show up Mike says okay this is the new offer you know Dana has shown up in Hawaii without her luggage what do we do next and how do we move forward from here and you're like no no no no wait go back let's make sure we get the luggage before we move on and in some ways it was the same dynamic that you described during improv. It is no, no, no, wait, go back. Let's make sure we get the luggage before we move on. And in some ways, it was the same dynamic that you described during improv.
在某些方面，我听到了你刚才说的关于即兴创作的回声，因为当然当行李没有出现时，迈克说，好吧，这是新的提议，你知道，达娜没带行李就到了夏威夷，我们接下来该怎么办，我们如何从这里继续前进？而你的反应是，不，不，不，不，等等，回去，让我们确保拿到行李再继续。在某种程度上，这与你在即兴创作期间描述的动态是一样的。这是不，不，不，等等，回去。让我们确保拿到行李再继续。在某种程度上，这与你在即兴创作期间描述的动态是一样的。
It is the same dynamic. And in improv, we call it accept and build. So you accept your scene partner's offer and you build upon it. And the worst thing of all to do is say no, but, because no, but doesn't get you anywhere. Even yes no but doesn't get you anywhere. Even yes but doesn't get you anywhere. It just highlights the problems. And so what I was doing in that moment was I was saying no but, yes but, I'm stressed but when I needed to just accept and build
这就是同样的动态。在即兴创作中，我们称之为“接受并构建”（accept and build）。所以你接受场景搭档的提议，并在此基础上继续构建。最糟糕的事情就是说“不，但是”（no, but），因为“不，但是”不会让你有任何进展。即使是“是的，不，但是”也不会让你有任何进展。即使是“是的，但是”（yes, but）也不会让你有任何进展。它只会凸显问题。所以我当时的做法是说“不，但是”，“是的，但是”，“我压力很大，但是”，而我其实只需要接受并构建
and say accept the situation and build upon it and go camping on a beach with my new Walmart shorts. Mike's fears about their compatibility didn't last long and they did not break up. In fact, they grew closer. We were best friends, totally in love. We got married in 2003. We had a baby boy in December of 2004 and then we moved into our new home in the suburbs in August 2005. So during this time you are finishing your graduate studies at the University of Pennsylvania but you were also interested in exploring a career in performance and comedy. And at one point, you took a job at a little television program called The Daily Show while
，说接受现状，在此基础上构建，穿着我从沃尔玛新买的短裤去海滩露营。迈克对他们契合度的担忧并没有持续多久，他们也没有分手。事实上，他们的关系更亲密了。我们成了最好的朋友，彼此深爱着对方。我们在2003年结婚。我们在2004年12月迎来了宝贝儿子，然后我们在2005年8月搬进了郊区的新家。所以在这期间，你正在宾夕法尼亚大学完成研究生学业，但你也对开拓演艺和喜剧事业感兴趣。有一次，你在一个名为《每日秀》（The Daily Show）的小型电视节目中找到了一份工作，当时
they were in town covering the Republican National Convention. Stephen Colbert was on the show at the time, and you got to talk with him about what life was like as a stand-up comedian. What did you ask him, and what did he tell you? He asked what I studied and I told him that I studied the effects of media on attitudes, knowledge, and behaviors. And he said, so what do you do next? And I said, well, I'm finishing my master's degree, but I'm thinking of going to New York to do improv. And he said, what would you do otherwise if you didn't go to New York? And I said, I would stay here at Penn and get my PhD and be a professor.
他们正在当地报道共和党全国代表大会。史蒂芬·科尔伯特（Stephen Colbert）当时也在节目中，你得以和他交流单口喜剧演员的生活是怎样的。你问了他什么，他又跟你说了什么？他问我学什么专业，我告诉他我研究的是媒体对态度、知识和行为的影响。他说，接下来你打算做什么？我说，嗯，我要完成我的硕士学位，但我正在考虑去纽约做即兴表演。他说，如果你不去纽约，你会做些什么？我说，我会留在宾大读博士，当一名教授。
He said, and if you did that, would you have to pay for it? I said, probably not. I would probably get a research assistantship from the university and have a tuition waiver. He said, why would you ever try to make it in comedy when you have this opportunity? And I couldn't believe it. I said, well, because I love making people laugh. And he said, I have been in this business such a long time, Dana. It has been grueling. It has been long, it's been arduous, and I love it, but there's a lot of rejection
他说，如果你那样做的话，你还得自费吗？我说，大概不用。我可能会从学校拿到研究助理津贴，并且免除学费。他说，既然你有这样的机会，为什么还要去喜剧界闯荡呢？我简直不敢相信。我说，嗯，因为我喜欢逗人笑。他说，我在这个行业待了很长时间了，达娜。这历程非常折磨人。这漫长而又艰辛，我虽然热爱它，但这里有很多拒绝，
and there's a lot of not knowing exactly where your next paycheck is gonna come from, right? And he said, I really think that you should get a PhD. And it wasn't like he and I were buddies, right? It was just, we had a very friendly relationship on the set, but he was just saying, look, I see you, and I see someone who is similar to me, and you do improv, and you're thinking
而且有很多时候你根本不知道下一张薪水支票会从哪里来，对吧？他说，我真的认为你应该去读个博士。而且并不是说我和他是哥们儿，对吧？只是我们在片场关系很融洽，但他只是说，看，我懂你，我看到一个和我相似的人，你做即兴表演，你在想
I'm gonna make it big. And he was like, it's a lot harder than you think. And that stayed with me. I'm wondering if he may have picked up on the fact that you are someone who does not deal well with uncertainty. And I think what he was painting was a picture that the life of a stand-up comic, a life in comedy, was a life that was filled with uncertainty.
我要成大名了。而他却觉得：这比你想象的要难得多。这句话深深地印在了我的脑海里。我在想，他可能已经察觉到你是一个不擅长应对不确定性的人。我想他当时描绘的画面是，单口喜剧演员的生活、喜剧界的生活，是一个充满不确定性的生活。
That is so wild. I've actually never thought of that. But I pretty much broadcast how I'm feeling at every moment on my face. So it's totally possible. So in many ways, life is going very well for you, Dana. You and Mike are married. You have a child, a son, you've just bought a new home. But later that year, Mike began having some medical problems. What was going on? Mike was always so healthy. I mean he didn't smoke cigarettes, he didn't drink alcohol, and he was very physically active. And in August of 2005, he started having bright flashes in his peripheral vision. And we didn't think
这太疯狂了。我其实从来没想过这一点。但我几乎在每个时刻都把自己的感受写在脸上。所以这完全是有可能的。所以在很多方面，达娜，你的生活非常顺利。你和迈克结了婚。你们有了个孩子，一个儿子，你们刚买了一个新家。但那年晚些时候，迈克开始出现一些健康问题。发生了什么？迈克一向非常健康。我的意思是，他不抽烟，不喝酒，而且身体非常活跃。在2005年8月，他的周边视力开始出现耀眼的闪光。我们当时没想
much of it, but I could tell that he was distracted by it and started to get kind of quiet. Saw an ophthalmologist who tell that he was distracted by it and started to get kind of quiet. I saw an ophthalmologist who said that he would need to go in to get an MRI. In October 2005, Mike went in for that MRI. The day the test results came out, Dana was at home working. The phone rang. When we come back, the call that changed Dana's life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
太多，但我能看出他因此分心，并开始变得有点沉默寡言。他去看了一位眼科医生，对方说他需要去做个核磁共振（MRI）。2005年10月，迈克去做了那次核磁共振。出检测结果的那天，达娜正在家里工作。电话响了。当我们回来时，这个电话改变了达娜的人生。你正在收听的是《隐藏的头脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedant. In 2005, Dana Young seemed to have it all. She was married to her best friend. Both of them had jobs they loved and they were also doing improv comedy together. They had a new home and a new baby. But that October, Mike began seeing bright flashes of light. His doctor recommended an MRI. Dana, on the day Mike went in for his scan, you were at home working. Can you tell me what happened? What happened? The phone rang like phones do. And it was Mike saying that the results confirmed
这里是《隐藏的头脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2005年，达娜·杨似乎拥有一切。她嫁给了自己最好的朋友。两人都有热爱的工作，他们还一起表演即兴喜剧。他们有了新家和一个刚出生的婴儿。但在那年10月，迈克开始看到明亮的闪光。他的医生建议做一个核磁共振。达娜，在迈克去做扫描的那天，你正在家里工作。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？发生了什么？电话像往常一样响了。电话里是迈克，他说结果证实了
that he had what the ophthalmologist had feared, which was a brain tumor pressing on his optic nerve. It just hit me in a way that you never really know when heavy news like that comes, how you're going to react. It just didn't feel real. He assured me, he said, if it is what he thinks it is, it's not cancerous and the prognosis would be really good because it's not something that's malignant, that's taking over other structures, but it means that we're gonna need to see a brain surgeon.
他患有眼科医生一直担心的疾病，即压迫视神经的脑部肿瘤。这个消息给我的打击，就像你永远不知道当这样沉重的消息袭来时，自己会做何反应一样。这感觉太不真实了。他安慰我，他说，如果结果和医生想的一样，那就不是癌症，而且预后会非常好，因为这不是恶性肿瘤，不会侵蚀其他组织，但这意味着我们需要去看脑外科医生。
This was gutting. I took to bed. I couldn't really get out of bed for a couple days. I had some friends who were trying to give me some tough love and say, you know, your baby boy needs a mom who's out of bed and you're not really helping Mike right now. It was very hard. Later that year, in November, Mike had the surgery that his doctors recommended.
这太令人肝肠寸断了。我躺在床上。我有好几天根本起不了床。有些朋友试图对我进行严厉的规劝，说：“你知道的，你的小男孩需要一个能起床的妈妈，你现在对迈克一点帮助也没有。”这非常艰难。那年晚些时候的11月，迈克做了医生建议的手术。
And it was quite successful. There were a few tiny cells that they could not remove because, as the surgeon put it, if we pull on those cells, Mike doesn't wake up. But unfortunately, the tumor grew back. So this was not benign then? It was benign, but the cells themselves, because it didn't take over other structures, right? But the problem is the brain is only so big and the skull is only so big. So there's only a certain amount of space. And when those cells began to themselves grow and filled with fluid, it created a cyst
手术相当成功。有几个极小的细胞是他们无法切除的，正如外科医生所说：“如果我们拉扯那些细胞，迈克就醒不过来了。”但不幸的是，肿瘤又长出来了。那这不就是良性的吗？它是良性的，但细胞本身，因为没有侵蚀其他结构，对吧？但问题是人类的大脑就这么大，头骨也就这么大。所以空间是有限的。当这些细胞开始自身生长并充满液体时，它形成了一个囊肿
that was even bigger than the original tumor. And it began to press on all of the regions of the brain that are responsible for vision and knowing you need to use the bathroom and the big one is memory. Mike lost his short-term memory which made living independently impossible. One evening Dana broke down with the unfairness of it all. We were not out of the woods and I cried and I said how unfair it of it all. We were not out of the woods.
甚至比最初的肿瘤还要大。它开始压迫大脑中负责视觉、感知你需要上厕所、以及最重要的大脑区域——记忆。迈克失去了短期记忆，这使得独立生活变得不可能。一天晚上，达娜终于因为这一切的极不公平而情绪崩溃。我们还没有脱离困境，我哭着说这一切太不公平了。我们还没有脱离困境。
And I cried and I said how unfair it was. It's just not fair. And he said, why is it not fair? I said, well, we're just starting out. We're just married. We're in love. We're best friends. We have a baby. We just bought a house. He said, who would it be fair to? Would it be more fair if I didn't have a partner? Would it be more fair if I didn't have a partner?
我哭着说这太不公平了。这太不公平了。他说，为什么不公平？我说，嗯，我们才刚刚开始。我们才刚结婚。我们相爱。我们是最好的朋友。我们有个孩子。我们刚买了一座房子。他说，对谁才公平呢？如果我没有伴侣会更公平吗？如果我没有伴侣会更公平吗？
Would it be more fair if I didn't have a baby? He had this way of saying things so simply and it really stopped me in my tracks. And I thought, well, he's right. Fairness has nothing to do with it. He said, it's not about fairness. It has nothing to do with fairness. It's just random.
如果我没有孩子会更公平吗？他有一种把事情说得极其简单的方式，这真的让我停下了脚步。我想，嗯，他说得对。公平与否跟这毫无关系。他说，这无关公平。这和公平一点关系也没有。这纯粹是随机的。
The universe is random. This is random. Did you find these words comforting, Dana? At the time I found them really frustrating. It felt like a very Mike thing to say, not like a very Dana thing to say. But it also made me understand that if I was going to be helpful to him, any kind of thoughts that I had about it being not fair or me being angry, I should probably not put in his lap. Yeah. I mean in some ways it's on a much much more serious scale. It's a
宇宙是随机的。这一切都是随机的。达娜，你觉得这些话能给你带来安慰吗？当时我真的觉得很沮丧。这感觉是很迈克式的回答，一点也不像达娜会说的话。但这也让我明白，如果我想对他的病情有所帮助，我内心任何关于“这不公平”或者“我很生气”的想法，大概都不应该倾倒在他身上。是的。我的意思是，在某种程度上，在规模大得多、严重得多的情况下，这其实是
variation of what happened once you landed in Hawaii and your luggage didn't show up. He's saying, well, these things happen, it's random, and you're saying, well, this is really unfair, and you're stuck on what actually happened. Yeah, exactly right. And it was like, just like with the luggage, I was like, but now I need to fix it.
你在夏威夷落地、行李没有出现时发生的事情的翻版。他说，好吧，这些事情会发生，这是随机的；而你的反应是，这太不公平了，然后你纠结于实际发生的事情。是的，完全正确。这就好像对待行李一样，我的反应是：“但现在我得把它修好。”
And he was like, or you could just enjoy the vacation because we're only here for seven days. And he was like, or you could just enjoy the vacation because we're only here for seven days. And with the brain tumor, I was so angry and so stuck. I was like, I just need to fix it. And I'm a lot of things, but I'm not a brain surgeon. So I started thinking maybe I can find the origins of where this came from. Maybe it came from his workplace. He works at a company and I know there was some other guy at this company who had cancer last year. So even though Mike's wasn't cancer, I thought, oh, well, maybe their workplace is making them sick. Then I thought, oh, well, in this new neighborhood that we moved to, there's this old diaper factory site that is an environmental
而他的反应是：“或者你也可以直接享受假期，因为我们只在这里待七天。”而他的反应是：“或者你也可以直接享受假期，因为我们只在这里待七天。”而面对脑瘤时，我是如此愤怒，如此纠结。我想的是：“我必须把它修好。”我有很多优点，但我不是脑外科医生。于是我开始思考，我是不是能找出这一切根源在哪里。也许它来自他的工作场所。他在一家公司工作，我知道去年这家公司还有另一个家伙得了癌症。所以尽管迈克的不是癌症，我想，哦，好吧，也许是他们的工作场所让他们生病的。然后我想，哦，好吧，在我们搬到的这个新社区里，有一个旧的尿布厂遗址，那是一个环境
problem and they're trying to clean it. Maybe that environmental site caused something. So I was on the internet for hours at night looking up like superfund sites, et cetera. And at this point now, Mike was back in the hospital because he had had complications. So this was probably like February and I'm really down the rabbit hole because now I'm really mad. Because now it's clear that he's not gonna be
问题，他们正在试图清理。也许那个环境污染遗址导致了某些问题。所以我连续好几个夜晚在互联网上搜索诸如超级基金场地（superfund sites）等信息。此时此刻，迈克因为并发症又回到了医院。所以这大概是在2月份，我真的陷入了阴谋论的兔子洞，因为我现在真的很生气。因为现在很明显，他的病
just one surgery, radiation and fine. So I started going into these sort of conspiracy theory rabbit holes on the internet. Why do you think you were doing this, Dana? It felt good. It felt really good. I felt completely out of control. And going down these rabbit holes gave me maybe people I could be mad at or companies I could be mad at. And I've learned since then that anger is such a weird emotion because we think of it as a negative emotion. But I think that ignores the fact that anger can bring about a sense of direction and optimism. Because it has a momentum to it. It has a target.
绝不仅仅是一次手术、放疗就能解决并痊愈的。于是我开始在互联网上钻进各种阴谋论的兔子洞。你觉得你当时为什么要这么做，达娜？感觉挺好的。感觉真的很好。我当时感到完全失控。而钻进这些兔子洞让我觉得找到了我可以去责怪的人，或者我可以去责怪的公司。从那以后我了解到，愤怒是一种非常奇怪的情绪，因为我们认为它是一种消极情绪。但我认为这忽视了一个事实，即愤怒可以带来一种方向感和乐观情绪。因为它带有某种动量。它有一个目标。
You're angry at someone. So it felt good. Mike passed away in 2006. In time, as Dana made her way through grief, she came to see that her own reaction to his illness reflected her extreme distaste for uncertainty. As a scholar, she was also studying how people deal with uncertainty in very different ways. One was how willing they were to cope with ambiguity. People who have a high tolerance for ambiguity tend to be really comfortable with situations that are uncertain and unpredictable.
你在对某人生气。所以这种感觉很好。迈克于2006年去世。随着时间的推移，当达娜逐渐走出悲伤时，她开始意识到，自己对他的病情的反应反映了她对不确定性的极度排斥。作为一名学者，她当时也在研究人们如何以截然不同的方式应对不确定性。其中之一就是他们应对模棱两可情况的意愿。对模糊有很高容忍度的人通常对不确定和不可预测的情况感到非常自在。
They're really okay with change. They don't need a lot of routine in their world. They can be spontaneous and it doesn't stress them out. And people who are high in need for closure are quite the opposite. They really prefer routine and order and structure and predictability in their lives, in their interactions, and in their sort of physical environments. Hmm. So the psychologist, Aryeh Kroglansky, once came up with a scale for this need for closure. I'm wondering if you could say more
他们真的很能接受改变。他们的世界不需要太多常规。他们可以很随性，而且这不会给他们带来压力。而对“追求闭合”（need for closure）需求很高的人则恰恰相反。他们在生活中、人际交往中以及某种身体环境中，非常偏爱常规、秩序、结构和可预测性。嗯。所以心理学家阿里耶·克鲁格兰斯基（Arie Kruglanski）曾经为此类“闭合需求”制定了一个量表。我在想，你能否多谈谈
about this body of research, Diana. Can you talk about some of the items on Kroglansky's checklist? Sure. It includes items including, I don't like situations that are uncertain. Okay. Now people are asked to say to what extent they agree or disagree with these. So I don't like situations that are uncertain. I dislike questions which could be answered
这方面的研究，达娜？你能谈谈克鲁格兰斯基清单上的几个条目吗？当然。它包括一些条目，比如：我不喜欢不确定的情况。好吧。现在人们被要求说明他们在多大程度上同意或不同意这些观点。所以——我不喜欢不确定的情况。我不喜欢那些可以用
in many different ways. I find that a well-ordered life with regular hours suits my temperament. I usually make important decisions quickly and confidently. If you find yourself agreeing with these statements, chances are you have a high need for closure. The scale also explores some dimensions that indicate a higher tolerance for ambiguity or a low need for closure. These are, I tend to struggle with most decisions. When considering most conflict situations, I can usually see how both sides could be right.
许多不同方式回答的问题。我发现生活规律、作息有常的井井有条的生活很适合我的性格。我通常能迅速而自信地做出重要决定。如果你发现自己同意这些说法，你很可能有着很高的闭合需求。该量表还探讨了表明对模糊性有较高容忍度或较低闭合需求的某些维度。这些维度是：我在做出大多数决定时往往会感到挣扎。在考虑大多数冲突情况时，我通常能看出双方都有各自的道理。
Need for closure is really designed to capture the extent to which individuals need a certain kind of order in their lives, in their interactions with others. And once you start thinking about both sides of this coin, right, high need for closure and high tolerance for ambiguity, as having equal sets of strengths and weaknesses, right, they're different strengths and different weaknesses, but they both can be wonderful and they both can be a hindrance. I mean, I'm thinking about what happened with you
闭合需求实际上旨在捕捉个体在生活以及与他人互动中需要某种特定秩序的程度。一旦你开始从硬币的两面来思考这个问题——一方面是高闭合需求，另一方面是对模糊性的高容忍度——它们拥有同等的一套优势和劣势，对吧？它们有不同的优势和不同的劣势，但它们既可以非常美妙，也可能会成为一种阻碍。我的意思是，我在回想你
and with Mike once he got this diagnosis. You went down these rabbit holes of trying to establish if it was some toxic chemical from the diaper factory that had caused him to get sick. And really what you're looking for is, I'm dealing with a situation of high ambiguity, high uncertainty, and if I can just locate the culprit that's responsible for all of this, in some ways it moves you from that world of uncertainty to a world of predictability and closure. And this is why this trait has become so pivotal in research on belief in conspiracy theories
和迈克在他确诊后发生的事情。你陷入了试图确定是否是尿布厂的某种有毒化学物质导致他生病的兔子洞。而你真正在寻找的是：我正在处理一个高度模糊、高度不确定的情况，如果我能找出应对这一切负责的罪魁祸首，在某种程度上，这就能将你从不确定性的世界带到一个可预测和闭合的世界。这就是为什么这个特质在关于相信阴谋论
and misinformation. Conspiracy theory beliefs are really rooted in a very simple causal mechanism. They say that whatever the crisis is or the horrible event is, it's not some complex systemic thing. It is something that has been caused by powerful people operating in the shadows to benefit themselves and harm others. And it provides a really quick closure to what could be a complex problem. There's another trait that's related to our capacity for uncertainty and it's called a high need for cognition. What does this mean, Dana? So high need for cognition is something that
和虚假信息的研究所占的核心地位。对阴谋论的信仰实际上根植于一种非常简单的因果机制。他们声称，无论危机是什么，或者可怕的事件是什么，都不是因为某些复杂的系统性问题。而是由在暗中操纵的权势人物为了自己的利益、损害他人而造成的。它为复杂的问题提供了一种非常快速的闭合。还有另一个特质与我们应对不确定性的能力有关，它被称为“对认知的需求”（high need for cognition）。这意味着什么，达娜？所以，“对认知的高需求”这个概念
comes to us from researchers named Cacioppo and Petty. And they introduced a theory of persuasion and they thought, you know, some people, it's not that they're smarter necessarily. It's not that they have more knowledge necessarily. It's that they really just enjoy thinking for the sake of thinking. And people who enjoy thinking actually are less likely to be persuaded by more emotional or heuristic kind of appeals. They require evidence
源于研究人员卡西奥波（Cacioppo）和佩蒂（Petty）。他们提出了说服理论，他们认为，你知道，有些人，倒不是说他们一定更聪明。也不是说他们一定拥有更多知识。而是他们真的只是为了思考而享受思考。而那些喜欢思考的人实际上更不容易被更具情感或启发式（heuristic）的诉求说服。他们需要
based argumentation to be persuaded by information. They're more analytical in other words. Exactly. How is this connected to our capacity to deal with uncertainty, or how does it influence it? I think about need for cognition as something that's a bit of a luxury, because if you're high in need for cognition, it signals that you have the time, you feel that you have the time and security to be able to dedicate to thinking about something for a long period of time. Having high need for cognition is actually correlated with people who are less likely to be monitoring their environments for threat. If you're not monitoring for threat and you're not looking around the corner to see who's lurking, you can just, you know, I call it cud chewing, you can chew your cud all day.
基于证据的论证才能被信息说服。换句话说，他们更具分析性。没错。这与我们应对不确定性的能力有什么联系，或者它是如何影响这一能力的？我认为对认知的高需求有点像一种奢侈品，因为如果你有很高的高认知需求，这就表明你有时间——你觉得你有时间和安全感能够全身心地投入到对某事进行长时间的思考中。拥有对认知的高需求实际上与那些较少监测环境中威胁的人相关联。如果你不监测威胁，也不四处张望看看谁在潜伏，你就可以，你知道的，我称之为“反刍”（cud chewing），你可以一整天都在反刍。
You could write a cost-benefit analysis of every possible decision you could make. You can write your pro-con list and you can just sit there and think. So in many ways our brains are wired to make sense of the world. We are sense-making animals, and each of these traits in some way speaks to our drive to make sense. How quickly do we need to make sense of the world? How much are we willing to live with uncertainty?
你可以为你可能做出的每一个决定写一份成本效益分析。你可以写下你的利弊清单，然后就坐在那里思考。所以在很多方面，我们的大脑天生就是为了理解世界而构建的。我们是寻求意义的动物，而这些特质中的每一个都在某种程度上体现了我们对寻找意义的驱动力。我们需要以多快的速度来理解世界？我们愿意与不确定性共存到什么程度？
This difference turns out to have ramifications in all kinds of different areas. One of the areas that you have looked at and others have looked at is in our appreciation of aesthetics. Can you talk about how our capacity to deal with uncertainty, these different factors, our tolerance for ambiguity, our need for closure, how it affects our perceptions of art? The research on the psychology of aesthetics and aesthetic preferences is so cool. These are scholars who have looked at the psychological and personality traits that predict whether or not people enjoy abstract art or more realistic art.
事实证明，这种差异在各种不同的领域都会产生影响。你和其他人研究过的领域之一就是我们对审美的欣赏。你能谈谈我们处理不确定性的能力——这些不同的因素、我们对模糊性的容忍度、我们的闭合需求——是如何影响我们对艺术的看法的吗？关于美学心理学和审美偏好的研究太酷了。这些学者研究了预测人们是否喜欢抽象艺术或更现实主义艺术的心理和人格特质。
Whether people prefer stories with very clear endings where the plot is completely wrapped up at the end, or if they prefer stories where everything is kind of left open for us to interpret. These studies are so cool, and the one thing that is consistent across them, which really gets you thinking, is that people who are high in tolerance for ambiguity are the ones who are most appreciative of abstract art, first of all, and of stories that don't have clear endings. And we also find in this literature the role of need for cognition as well, that people who enjoy thinking about things and you know really kind of
研究人们是更喜欢结局非常清晰、情节在结尾完全交待清楚的故事，还是更喜欢一切都留白、供我们去解读的故事。这些研究太酷了，其中贯穿始终、让人深思的一点是，那些对模糊性有高容忍度的人，首先最懂得欣赏抽象艺术，其次也最欣赏没有明确结局的故事。我们在相关文献中也发现了认知需求的作用，即那些喜欢思考事物、你知道的，真的有点
struggling to solve problems, these are the same people who really enjoy abstract art and syncopated jazz for example over really predictable like pop music or country music that has a more predictable cadence, and verse structure. I understand that you sometimes explain the difference in how we perceive art by talking about two paintings involving women who wear hats. Yes, I was so excited when I, you know, it's very hard to find visuals
费力去解决问题的人，正是那些真正喜欢抽象艺术和切分音爵士乐（胜过真正可预测的流行音乐或更有可预测的节奏和诗节结构的乡村音乐）的人。我了解到，有时你会通过谈论两幅画有戴帽子女人的画作来解释我们对艺术认知的差异。是的，当我发现——你知道的，很难找到视觉效果
to illustrate some of these things, but I was so excited when I found that both Renoir But you know, it's very hard to find visuals to illustrate some of these things. But I was so excited when I found that both Renoir and Picasso had painted pictures of women wearing hats. Obviously, they look very different. Renoir's is realistic and features this beautiful, I would say, maybe 15-year-old girl wearing a hat. Picasso's is abstract.
来阐明其中一些事情——但我非常高兴，当我发现雷诺阿和毕加索都画过戴帽子的女人时。显然，它们看起来非常不同。雷诺阿的作品是现实主义的，描绘了一个美丽的、我想说可能15岁左右戴着帽子的女孩。毕加索的作品是抽象的，
The face is disjointed, the nose is large, and there's maybe a hat placed on the head a little bit-ish. So talking to my students about these traits and their relationship with aesthetic preferences, I like having these two images side by side to say, each of us is going to tend to gravitate towards one or the other. And you know think about what that means about yourself. You know studies show that everybody can kind of appreciate a depiction of reality that looks realish. You know we all like that. Where the real distinction comes is when you look at the predictors of who likes and who dislikes abstract art.
面部是脱节的，鼻子很大，头上可能有点像那样戴着一顶帽子。所以当我和学生们谈论这些特质及其与审美偏好的关系时，我喜欢把这两幅图像并排放在一起，说明我们每个人都会倾向于被其中一幅或另一幅所吸引。你知道，去思考这对你自己意味着什么。你知道，研究结果表明，每个人都能在某种程度上欣赏看起来有点真实的现实描绘。你知道，我们都喜欢那样。真正的区别在于，当你寻找谁喜欢、谁不喜欢抽象艺术的预测因素时。
And that's where these personality traits really play a role with the higher tolerance for ambiguity being more associated with appreciation for abstract art. And some of this work suggests that this is something that's explained by both need for cognition and this tolerance for ambiguity as well. I'm wondering how you yourself see those two paintings. Tell me how you feel about them. I really don't like the Picasso painting. I really don't. And I recently was in New York with my son. We went to MoMA and we were all excited because we're like, oh, wow, these are original Picasso's.
正是这些个性特质真正发挥了作用，对模糊性的更高容忍度与对抽象艺术的欣赏有更多关联。其中一些研究表明，这一点既可以用认知需求来解释，也可以用对模糊性的容忍度来解释。我很想知道你自己是如何看待这两幅画的。告诉我你的感受。我真的很不喜欢毕加索的那幅画。我真的不喜欢。我最近和儿子在纽约。我们去了现代艺术博物馆（MoMA），我们都很兴奋，因为我们想，哦，哇，这些是毕加索的真迹。
And there's one that's really big and all the women have fat hands and weird feet and triangle faces. And I got to tell you, I got to tell you, I just don't get it. And that probably makes me not sophisticated. I don't know. But man, I just don't get it. In some ways, I'm hearing your exasperation here, Dana. Well, kind of, because I'm like, you know,
其中有一幅真的很大，所有的女人都有着粗大的手、奇怪的脚和三角形的脸。我得告诉你，我得告诉你，我就是看不懂。这可能让我显得不够精致。我不知道。但是天哪，我就是看不懂。在某种程度上，我听到了你的恼怒，达娜。嗯，有点吧，因为我想，你知道的，
I think when I was like 10, I could probably have painted that. And I know that that's not true. I know he's a genius, blah, blah, blah. But yeah, I really do not enjoy it. The same thing happens with literature. What was your reaction to that ambiguous ending to the story of the lady and the tiger? When the world is uncertain or hard to understand this can be deeply unsatisfying for some. Others might find it curious, mysterious, and enticing. When we come back, how these traits shape our deepest beliefs and cause conflicts
我想我大概10岁的时候也能画出那个。我知道这不是真的。我知道他是天才，等等等等。但是，是的，我真的不喜欢它。文学作品中也会发生同样的事情。你对《美女还是老虎》这个故事那个模棱两可的结局有什么反应？当世界充满不确定性或难以理解时，这对某些人来说可能会感到极其不满足。其他人可能会觉得它很好奇、很神秘、很诱人。当我们回来时，我们将探讨这些特质如何塑造我们最深层的信仰并引发人们之间的冲突，
between people, and how we can bridge those divides. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all view the world differently. Some of us see it as unpredictable and dangerous. Others see possibilities and room for exploration. Dana Young is the author of Wrong, How Media, Politics and Identity Drive Our Appetite for Misinformation. She says much of the way we view the world comes down to how we tolerate uncertainty. Some of us are more okay than others with ambiguity,
以及我们如何弥合这些分歧。你正在收听的是《隐藏的头脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的头脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们所有人对世界的看法各不相同。我们中的一些人认为它是不可预测且危险的。另一些人则看到了种种可能和探索的空间。达娜·杨是《错误：媒体、政治与身份如何驱动我们对虚假信息的需求》（Wrong, How Media, Politics and Identity Drive Our Appetite for Misinformation）一书的作者。她说，我们看待世界的大部分方式归根结底取决于我们如何容忍不确定性。我们中的一些人比其他人更能接受模棱两可、
unpredictability and randomness. How we respond to life's gray areas informs everything from our career choices to our preferences in art and literature. It can also influence our political beliefs. Dana, we like to think our politics are informed by logic and values and traditions, but even these beliefs might be shaped by our capacity to deal with uncertainty. Let's go back to one of those traits that influence how we deal with uncertainty. This is the need for cognition.
不可预测性和随机性。我们对生活中灰色地带的反应，决定了从我们的职业选择到我们对艺术和文学的偏好的方方面面。它甚至会影响我们的政治信仰。达娜，我们喜欢认为我们的政治观点是由逻辑、价值观和传统决定的，但甚至连这些信仰也可能是由我们处理不确定性的能力塑造的。让我们回到影响我们处理不确定性的其中一个特质。这就是认知需求。
Some of us enjoy thinking and complexity more than others do. How does this trait correlate with our political beliefs? There is some wonderful work from political psychology that looks at the trait need for cognition. So for example, there's some work by Michael Sargent from 2004 that showed that for people who were highest in need for cognition, they tended to be the least supportive of highly punitive measures in response to criminals or in the context of crime. And in a subsequent study, trying to understand what explained that,
我们中的一些人比其他人更享受思考和复杂性。这个特质与我们的政治信仰有怎样的相关性？来自政治心理学的一些精彩研究探讨了认知需求这一特质。例如，迈克尔·萨金特（Michael Sargent）在2004年做过一项研究，结果表明，对于那些认知需求最高的人来说，他们往往最不支持针对罪犯或在犯罪背景下采取高度惩罚性的措施。在随后的研究中，为了解背后的原因，
it was that people higher in need for cognition were probably more motivated to consider more complex ways of attributing responsibility for why individuals would have engaged in these criminal acts in the first place. So a high need for cognition allows people to think beyond simple causal mechanisms of bad person does bad thing and to think perhaps more systemically about other factors that may have been responsible for that criminal act in the first place.
认知需求较高的人可能更有动力去考虑更复杂的归因方式，以解释为什么个人最初会参与这些犯罪行为。因此，较高的认知需求使人们能够超越“坏人做坏事”这种简单的因果机制，或许能更系统地思考导致该犯罪行为的其他潜在因素。
There are many examples of studies looking at similar kinds of things that show need for cognition has this kind of influence on politically relevant or even politically central belief systems. When you step back and look at the overall body of research, what does it reveal about the differences between liberals and conservatives when it comes to this idea of a need for cognition? I think about this in terms of how people monitor for threats in their environment. And when I think about it that way, it actually gives me sort of a unifying narrative that helps explain a lot of what's going on.
有许多研究探讨了类似的问题，表明认知需求对政治相关甚至政治核心的信仰系统具有这种影响。当你退一步审视整体研究时，它揭示了自由派和保守派在认知需求这个概念上的哪些区别？我从人们如何监测环境中威胁的角度来思考这个问题。当我从这个角度去想时，它实际上给我提供了一种能够解释许多现象的统一叙事。
I think that based on what we know now, it seems that individuals are born, perhaps genetically, right, predisposed to have physiological systems that deal with threat in their environment. And that shapes physiological patterns, which then shape psychological tendencies. And for people who are high threat monitors, they are all about survival in the face of threat and it's on their mind all the time. What serves these people best is making decisions quickly and efficiently based on heuristics, emotions, intuition, and shortcuts. That is what causes them to have this lower need for cognition. It's not that they can't, it's that it doesn't make sense for them based on their sort of psychophysiological predispositions. Similarly, these are folks who, because they're monitoring for threat, of course they're going to want to be in situations that are highly certain, ordered, predictable. They're not going to be very high in tolerance for ambiguity because that exposes them to threat.
我认为，根据我们目前所了解的情况，个人在出生时（也许是通过基因）就具有应对环境中威胁的生理系统的倾向。这塑造了生理模式，进而塑造心理倾向。对于那些高度监测威胁的人来说，他们的一切都是为了在威胁面前生存，这件事时刻占据着他们的脑海。对这些人最有利的做法是，根据直觉、情感、直觉和捷径，快速且高效地做出决策。这就是导致他们认知需求较低的原因。并不是说他们做不到，而是根据他们的心理生理倾向，这样做对他们来说没有意义。同样地，由于这些人时刻在监测威胁，他们自然会希望身处高度确定、有序且可预测的环境中。他们对模糊性的容忍度不会很高，因为这会让他们暴露在威胁之下。
Hmm. And again, if you were to think about, you know, the stereotypical example of being under threat, you know, there's a, I don't know, an active shooter in the vicinity or you're in a jungle somewhere and there might be a, you know, a tiger hiding in the bushes, you know, that's not the time when you want to spend a lot of time thinking through your options and thinking through what might be a tiger hiding in the bushes. That's not the time when you want to spend a lot of time thinking through your options and thinking through what might be causing it or thinking about the systemic reasons the tiger might want to eat you.
嗯。而且再想想，如果你去想象那种处于威胁之中的刻板印象，比如，我不知道，附近有一个持枪歹徒，或者你在某片丛林里，灌木丛里可能藏着一只老虎，你知道，那可不是花大量时间权衡各种选项、思考到底是什么藏在灌木丛里的时候。那绝对不是花大量时间思考各种可能性、琢磨老虎为什么要吃你的系统性原因的时候。
That in fact is a time for decisive action. And what you're saying is that some people in some ways are quicker to move into the mind state of being the person walking in the forest and hearing a twig crack behind them. Absolutely right. And this is why, and remember, I'm a college professor.
那实际上是采取果断行动的时刻。你的意思是，某些人在某种程度上能更快地进入那种“走在森林里听到身后树枝折断”的心理状态。完全正确。这就是为什么——记住，我是一名大学教授。
I have been one for 17 years. I'm also a comedian. I've been one for 30 years. Do you know who I wouldn't want with me in the jungle? I wouldn't want a faculty colleague or a fellow comedian. You don't want someone saying yes and? I really don't. I don't because you know what's gonna happen? I'm gonna be shot and eaten by a tiger. So you've conducted a study, Dana, that looks at how our psychological traits might inform our opinions on transgender issues.
我当了17年教授。我同时也是一名喜剧演员，干了30年。你知道我最不想和谁一起去丛林吗？我可不想和我的大学同事或同行喜剧演员在一起。你难道不想找个会说“好，而且……”的人吗？我真的不想。我才不要，因为你知道会发生什么吗？我会被老虎枪杀并吃掉。所以，达娜，你做过一项研究，探讨我们的心理特征如何影响我们对跨性别问题的看法。
Tell me about this work and what you found. So with my colleagues at the University of Delaware, we looked at, in a survey, we looked at whether or not individuals who had higher or lower need for closure had different levels of support for transgender individuals. What we found is that even accounting for all these other things, need for closure is associated with more negative opinions of transgender people, transgender candidates,
跟我讲讲这项工作以及你的发现。我和特拉华大学的同事们在一次调查中发现，无论是高认知闭合需求还是低认知闭合需求的人，对跨性别者的支持水平是否存在差异。我们发现，即使把所有这些其他因素都考虑进去，认知闭合需求也与对跨性别者、跨性别候选人更负面的看法相关联。
and transgender rights. And this is one of those things that is intuitive on its face. And when we thought about studying this construct, I just thought, you know, for folks who need for there to be a yes or no answer, black and white, it would make sense for these folks, the concept of gender fluidity or the concept of gender being a social construct, that I could imagine that that might be hard for them to reconcile. And sure enough, our results actually showed quite a robust effect of need for closure on these outcomes. Tana, we talked earlier about how Stephen Colbert gave you some advice that changed
以及跨性别者的权利。这正是那种表面上就很直观的事情之一。当我们考虑研究这个概念时，我只是觉得，对于那些需要是非分明、非黑即白的答案的人来说，性别流动的概念或者性别是一个社会建构的概念，对他们来说可能很难接受。果不其然，我们的研究结果确实显示出认知闭合需求对这些结果具有相当强烈的显著影响。达娜，我们之前谈到斯蒂芬·科尔伯特曾给你提供过一条建议，它改变了
your life. Many years ago, Colbert had a show on Comedy Central where he played a character of sorts. I want to play you a clip from the show which was called The Colbert Report. I just want to say that I am not a racist. I don't even see race, not even my own. People tell me I'm white and I believe them because I just devoted six minutes to explaining how I'm not a racist. So it's clear, Diana, that Colbert isn't being serious, but can you talk about the kind of
你的人生。多年前，科尔伯特在喜剧中心频道有一个节目，他在其中扮演某种角色。我想放一段该节目的剪辑给你听，这个节目叫《科尔伯特报告》。我只想说，我不是种族主义者。我甚至看不到种族，连我自己的都看不到。人们告诉我我是白人，我相信他们，因为我刚刚花了六分钟来解释我不是种族主义者。所以很明显，戴安娜，科尔伯特并不是认真的，但你能聊聊他展现的那种
humor that he is putting on display? It is quintessential ironic satire. Irony is a kind of humor that is created through an inversion of meaning. And so what Stephen Colbert does is, he says the opposite of what he means. The valence is actually the opposite of what he intends for us to take away.
幽默吗？这是典型的讽刺性幽默。讽刺是一种通过颠倒语义来创造的幽默。因此，斯蒂芬·科尔伯特所做的就是，他说出他真实意图的反面。其语意实际上与他打算让我们领会的意思完全相反。
So there have been studies that examine what happens in the brain when people are processing texts like this, where it requires the listener to understand the intent of the message sender and to reconcile that intent with the literal words that are being stated. And it turns out that it's actually quite complex cognitively. I think about it as kind of mental gymnastics because you're thinking about intent, you're
因此，有一些研究检查了当人们处理此类文本时大脑中会发生什么，这种文本需要听众理解信息发送者的意图，并将该意图与所陈述的字面意思相调和。事实证明，这在认知上实际上相当复杂。我把这看作是一种心理体操，因为你要思考意图，你
reading literal words, you're thinking about whether or not those match with what you know about the message sender, you're bringing old information to bear on the text. Turns out that for people who are really high in need for cognition, this is a kind of riddle-solving that's quite enjoyable. But for people lower in need for cognition, this kind of irony, this kind of ambiguity in a text is very challenging and not that enjoyable. I want to compare that Stephen Colbert clip with a clip from the late conservative media host Rush Limbaugh. Here he is.
在阅读字面文字，思考这些文字是否与你对信息发送者的了解相符，并把过去的背景信息应用到文本中。事实证明，对于认知需求极高的人来说，这是一种非常有趣的解谜过程。但对于认知需求较低的人来说，这种讽刺、文本中的这种模糊性是非常具有挑战性的，而且没那么有趣。我想把斯蒂芬·科尔伯特的这段剪辑与已故保守派媒体主持人拉什·林堡的一段剪辑进行对比。他就在这里。
I'm sick and tired of being afraid of these people. I'm sick and tired of people acting intimidated by Democrats. This fear of being called a racist. Everybody's raci... They can't talk about anybody now without labeling them racist. So I'm hearing a very different tone in this clip, Dana. Very different tone. And this is why I refer, my first book is called Irony and Outrage as a way of sort of shorthanding the real huge distinctions that exist between these two genres. Outrage isn't necessarily only on the political right, okay? But we tend to see it more on the right.
我厌倦了害怕这些人。我厌倦了人们表现得对民主党人感到畏惧。这种被称为种族主义者的恐惧。每个人都是种族主义者……现在他们谈论任何人时都避不开给他们贴上种族主义者的标签。所以在这段剪辑中，我听到了截然不同的语气，达娜。非常不同的语气。这就是为什么我把我的第一本书命名为《讽刺与愤怒》，以此作为一种简写方式，来指代这两种流派之间存在的巨大真实差异。愤怒并不一定只存在于政治右翼，好吗？但我们倾向于在右翼看到更多这种现象。
The nature of outrage is it identifies threats in our environment, it highlights them in an emotional and dramatic way, it does so didactically, very clearly, usually using some kind of hyperbole or slippery slope language that is, I would say, not just emotional but like supercharged. It is highly activating.
愤怒的本质是它能识别我们环境中的威胁，以一种情绪化且戏剧化的方式突出它们，它以说教的方式、非常清晰地表达出来，通常会使用某种夸张或滑坡谬误的语言，我要说的是，这不仅仅是情绪化的，而且是超级充能的。它是高度激活的。
Hmm. And in some ways, this brings us to a very interesting conclusion. If you look out over the media landscape of political commentary, liberal shows tend to have a very different feel to them than conservative shows. Correct. The liberal quote unquote outrage shows are actually not nearly as outrageous as the conservative outrage shows that you would see on Fox in terms of their use of, again, being emotional, hyperbolic, identifying threats, et cetera. And part of my struggle was trying to understand why we don't see a lot of conservative satire.
嗯。在某种程度上，这把我们带向了一个非常有趣的结论。如果你放眼政治评论的媒体格局，自由派节目给人的感觉往往与保守派节目大不相同。没错。从使用情绪化、夸张手法、识别威胁等方面来看，自由派所谓的“愤怒节目”其实远不如你在福克斯频道看到的保守派愤怒节目那么具有煽动性。我纠结的一部分原因在于，试图理解为什么我们看不到很多保守派讽刺作品。
Why do we not see a lot of conservative satire? And that's what got me thinking about all of these traits that I had been fascinated by and how they might be related here. And I think that that is really what's at the heart of the matter. These traits of tolerance for ambiguity and need for cognition, they do cluster on the social and cultural left. And their opposites do cluster on the social and cultural right. And so to the extent that the people who are making these shows are of those ideological groups, and to the extent that they're trying to activate and appeal to audiences who are also of those
为什么我们看不到很多保守派讽刺作品？这让我开始思考所有这些让我着迷的特征，以及它们可能与此有何关联。我认为这才是问题的核心。对模糊性的容忍度和认知需求这些特征确实在社会和文化左翼中聚集。而它们的对立面则在社会和文化右翼中聚集。因此，就制作这些节目的那些人属于这些意识形态群体而言，且就他们试图激活和吸引同样属于这些意识形态群体的受众而言，
ideological groups, then naturally we're going to see these traits sort of manifest in the kinds of content that they create. You have Fox News very much in the spirit of Limbaugh with their opinion hosts, really appealing to people who are driven by a need for closure, threat monitoring, and who are really just seeking to know, who do I need to be worried about and angry at and what do I need to be worried about and angry at, and what do I need to do? One thing that strikes me though, Dana, is that because we're not seeing how our tolerance for uncertainty might be shaping how we think, you know, we find ourselves constantly at odds with other people and bewildered by their choices. We don't say, you know, okay, she has a higher need for cognition and therefore wants to understand the context that lead to crime. You know, we say she must be a snowflake. We don't say he has a more acute sense of threat and wants to keep our
自然而然地，我们就会看到这些特征在他们创作的内容中表现出来。福克斯新闻非常契合林堡的精神，其意见主持人们真正吸引的是那些受闭合需求和威胁监测驱动的人，他们只是想知道：我需要担心谁、生谁的气？我需要担心和生气什么？我又该做些什么？然而，让我震惊的一点是，达娜，由于我们没有看到我们对不确定性的容忍度如何塑造我们的思考方式，你知道的，我们发现自己总是与其他人意见相左，并对他们的选择感到困惑。我们不会说，“哦，她的认知需求更高，因此想了解导致犯罪的背景。”你知道的，我们会说，“她肯定是个脆弱敏感的人（雪花）。”我们不会说，“他的威胁意识更敏锐，想保护我们的
community safe. We say, you know, he's a gun-toting extremist. So in some ways we simplify the world without realizing that in some ways our perceptions of the world are shaped by these underlying psychological traits. And part of the reason that that has happened is because the way that our media environment capitalizes on these mega political identities as shortcuts that can activate us and outrage us and get us to pay attention so that they can sell us things or they can get us to vote a certain way. This is part of this machinery that I call the identity distillation machinery of our current media environment.
社区安全。”我们会说，“他是个携带枪支的极端分子。”因此，在某种程度上，我们简化了世界，却没有意识到在某些方面我们对世界的感知正是由这些潜在的心理特征塑造的。发生这种情况的部分原因是，我们的媒体环境利用了这些巨型政治身份作为捷径，能够激活我们、激怒我们，让我们集中注意力，这样他们就可以向我们推销东西，或者让我们以某种方式投票。这是我称之为当前媒体环境的“身份蒸馏机制”的机器的一部分。
I think of course what we're getting at here, Dana, is that there are excellent reasons to be decisive and also excellent reasons to think about all the details. There's an advantage to coming up with explanations for things and advantages to sitting with ambiguity. The fact that we have these different systems in our minds testifies to the fact that the world throws lots of different kinds of problems at us, and we would be wise to recognize that different problems probably have different solutions. And that we can tap into those different tendencies within us depending upon what the situation is. From my vantage point, I also think about it at the system level,
我认为我们在这里探究的当然是，保持果断有极好的理由，而思考所有细节同样有极好的理由。提出解释事物的原因有其优势，而安于模糊也有其优势。我们脑海中拥有这些不同的系统，这一事实证明了世界向我们抛出了许多不同类型的问题，我们如果能够认识到不同的问题可能需要不同的解决方案，那就是明智的。并且我们可以根据具体情况调动我们内部的这些不同倾向。从我的角度来看，我也从系统层面来思考这个问题，
where a society that only has people who are tolerant of ambiguity and high in need for cognition, well, it might be a society that has art and music and innovation, but it might also be a society that could be attacked and taken over very quickly, right? A society that only has high need for closure and low need for cognition, that is a society that might be super safe, super high in law and order, but might not have the kind of innovations and exploration,
在一个只有包容模糊性且认知需求高的人的社会里，好吧，这可能是一个拥有艺术、音乐和创新的社会，但它也可能是一个会遭到攻击并很快被占领的社会，对吧？一个只有高闭合需求和低认知需求的人的社会，那可能是一个超级安全、法治健全的社会，但可能没有那种能让生活质量真正丰富的创新、探索、艺术和文化。
art and culture that would make quality of life really rich. So, you know, thinking about these two things as the yin and the yang of society, rather than things that need to be demonized if they don't share with how we live our lives, I think is necessary. Danigal Goldthwey-Tiang studies the media, public opinion, and political satire at the University of Delaware.
所以，你知道，把这两者看作社会的阴和阳，而不是当它们与我们的生活方式不同时就妖魔化它们，我认为这是必要的。达娜·戈德霍伊-蒂昂（Dana Goldthwaite-Young）在特拉华大学研究媒体、公众舆论和政治讽刺。
She's the author of Wrong, How Media, Politics, and Identity Drive Our Appetite for Misinformation, and Irony and Outrage, the Polarized Landscape of Rage, Fear and Laughter in the United States. Dana, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me on. Maybe use these ideas as an opportunity for deeper conversation. An opportunity to go beyond headlines and hot button issues and understand the underlying drivers of their beliefs. If you do engage in such conversations, let us know how they go. You can also send us follow-up questions for Danigal Young. To do so, please find a quiet room, record a voice memo on your phone,
她是《错误：媒体、政治和身份如何驱使我们对虚假信息的渴求》（Wrong, How Media, Politics, and Identity Drive Our Appetite for Misinformation）和《讽刺与愤怒：美国愤怒、恐惧与笑声的极化景观》（Irony and Outrage, the Polarized Landscape of Rage, Fear and Laughter in the United States）的作者。达娜，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。也许可以把这些想法当作一个深入对话的机会。这是一个超越头条新闻和热点问题、理解其信仰潜在驱动力的机会。如果你确实参与了这样的对话，请让我们知道进展如何。你也可以向达娜·戈德霍伊-蒂昂发送后续问题。为此，请找一个安静的房间，在手机上录制语音备忘录，
and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Sixty seconds is plenty. Please use the subject line, uncertainty. Please also be sure to pronounce your name and let us know if we have permission to use your recording in a future episode of the show. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul,
并将其通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再重复一遍邮箱地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。六十秒就足够了。请使用主题：uncertainty（不确定性）。同时也请确保准确读出您的名字，并让我们知道是否授权我们在节目的未来单集里使用您的录音。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔（Annie Murphy-Paul）、
Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains' executive editor. If you're a longtime fan of the show, you know why you like listening to podcasts. Podcasts are a great alternative to doom-scrolling on social media. They can help you learn new ideas while you're on a walk
克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你是该节目的老粉丝，你就会知道你为什么喜欢听播客。播客是社交媒体上无休止刷手机（doom-scrolling）的一个绝佳替代方案。它们可以帮助你在散步
or washing the dishes. Maybe podcasts also keep you company and make you feel connected to the world around you. Whatever your reason for listening to podcasts, we really appreciate you spending your time with us. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或洗碗时了解新的观点。也许播客还能陪伴你，让你感受到与周围世界的联系。无论你收听播客的原因是什么，我们都非常感激你花时间陪伴我们。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们很快再见。音乐 本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。